serge chapleau bonjour à l'eau on est à
quelques heures du déclenchement d'une
élection qui l'a d'abord est ce que vous
vous en avez tellement fait de quentin
ça vous stimule encore ça vous inspire
encore une quentin
ça me stimule c'est laid ça m'inspire
pas vraiment parce que je trouve qu'ici
3 min
il donnait il va avoir quelque chose une
déclaration de le groupe commence à
faire un dessin puis le lendemain en a
une autre ton gagne pause puis ils sont
beaucoup plus drôle de moi pendant
pendant la campagne électorale et ça va
beaucoup plus vite qu'un vin vous etes
infernale à 10 heures le matin qu'on
pense qui la grosse nouvelle a4
arsenault en plus si le genre d'humour
qui s'est transformé au niveau des
policiers c'est je regardais il a
annoncé sacs à pain je vous annonce très
bien mesdames et messieurs je vous
annonce que ça va être le 20 mai samedi
et sur le drame avait été un bain
bonjour tout le monde j'ai le plaisir de
vous annoncer que la campagne électorale
va déclencher à 6 6 6 qui est en train
de faire là je comprends même pas par la
technique oui ça me fascine pas cette
époque vraiment ma vie j'essaie de
l'ancien gap alex t'oublie sort parce
que le mec va voir autre chose ça va
très vite très vite est-ce que les
caractères vous inspirait ce convoi
monsieur qu est-ce que vous ça s'est
transformé au fil d abord je
me rappelle d'avoir dessiné jacquet
détient mille fois c'est parti de
monsieur puis ça finit par un aux jambes
mais ce fut le temps différent que mme
bocher
oui ça se transforme ta prêt à
travailler avec le monsieur gable je
veux garder ici on présente nos amis
passent toutes par écran mais dans le
détail les gens veulent jouer il ya plus
de crayon ayant rapidement et on a
encore le guardian tables des siens côté
de toi mais c'est que ça il m'est très
bien on s'habitue sauvegardes
basées
sur cet écran maintenant oui ok une fois
de temps en temps quelques esquisses que
j'adore faire encore tiens le gars tu
veux je prends la face klich il ne sert
à quelque chose
c'est la magie de photoshop un seul de
ses six
gardes on veut on va le faire un peu
plus
un peu plus sombre
tous
puis le faciès de monsieur legault un
autre personnage de lui j pas très
content mais dans le moment est beaucoup
plus contactez
savate et les biens sont à peine d agir
de parisot c'est parce que cependant
cette image là et c'est en vendant mode
politiciens on va le mettre 50 en tenue
plus tôt en niveaux de gris
ccsa sans votre mot disque les cycles
regardez juste on sait quoi les leçons
bull continuerons notre tombe mal car si
maurice bessy kétamine et trois rivères
continueront la de l'oeuvre de monsieur
difficile donc ça souligne de force du
play vous vous risquez travailler là
dessus les louis sûr de lui absolument
un père la nation ne faut jamais si
jamais ce corps si mon expérience de vie
ailleurs dans quels cas tu
faut jamais passé qu'est ce qui va
arriver
s'il voulait que la politique change
c'est que l'équipe est passée amour
beaucoup beaucoup de coups de choses
dans le moment ça va tellement bien
qu'il pense et il est faible il est ou
non mais moi je n'y peux citer sa tenue
mais ils vont avoir beaucoup trop de
deux députés là il y en a qui sont pas
contents ils sont pour menace toute la
gamme dans le plusieurs que m'ont dit
poids
dominique anglade comment vous vient
pour que j'aie de mêlée car ladite
toujours un pull à nîmes ça provient
toujours la même affaire que nous
n'expliquons elle est un peu à vue de la
vente présente ses seuls dominique
anglade
bien dans nos esprits et et quel moment
donné ça va être plus que ça mais moi je
la trouve très intéressant de minix neuf
femmes ville que l'intelligent tient en
partage ce jour que je respecte beaucoup
une politicienne je veux jamais c'est
vrai sont encore pauvre il ya bien sûr
des idiots bien sûr des moins que rien
des totaux d ordinaire tu fais toujours
le même blague en disant au niveau
fédéral le garde s'est pas conditionné
d'essais maxime bernier
maxime bernier que vous avez dessiné un
clown
rien à faire avec ça mais les autres
c'est déjà beaucoup d'honnêteté la donne
mais quand il tombe en politique après
ça ici maj une certaine intelligence
d'être capable de juger tirso peuple
vente comprend regarde nos amis ici un
dunk qui s'appelle biron qui s'est
laissé le côté journalistes et les
partis politiques qui le land mais le
dit que toi ioniens c'était quand même
un bon projet
m'excuse un peu
pardon de la mémoire pour faire ces
jeunes profs ou non mais il faut voir la
mémoire il faut suit vous suivez
vraiment détail l'actualité quotidienne
malchanceux presque autant que vous oui
sa job c'est 24 70 c'est un bulletin de
nouvelles déclarations toutes les passes
en plus vous j'aille voir d'autres
mondes même si m
j'étais là faudrait toutefois tout coule
fois que le souverain faux baignade et
ça vous avez encore le goût et ça je me
sens encore beaucoup beaucoup plus en
plus ça donne un regard je nous trouve
privilégié d'être capable dans une
position de regarder ce
mois c'est un humour dont vous faites
des nouvelles faut s'asseoir choisir
quelle part des d'acta d'eau qu'est ce
qu'on fait partie de son appartement
conte moral mais c'est la même chose
mais moi je plutôt solitaire seul dans
mon coin etes-vous journalistes non plus
tôt dit le seul dans son coin
éditorialistes mai même lors de ses
organes mes amis moi je participe à tous
les matins meeting éditorial la presse
ou s'intéressant et j'écoute beaucoup
plan dena ça donne beaucoup de sujets
beaucoup d'opinions différentes mais moi
j'ai le droit de me tromper les mains
nues quand un texte son éditorial c'est
un malade de quelques faussetés tu vas
te faire rentrer dedans moi je fais un
dessin si je me trompe vous recommencez
là mais est ce qu'il ya des fois où vous
dites je me suis vraiment trop et je
regrette un dessin moi je regrettais
d'usagé dans la jeunesse maintenant je
fais attention vous avez souvent dit
c'est comme marcher sur une corde raide
week-end wyeth sûr et c'est un trait
trop à gauche un très trop exagérer
c'est l'erreur puis vous tombez est ce
que ça vous êtes conscients à chaque
fois vous chaque matin vous commencez un
dessin puis maintenant parce que je me
rends compte que je peux tomber incombe
au dessus de la cote de l'aide mais
c'est le fou du roi effectivement tu
peux être lemercier tu peux te fais
couper avec ce qui est le plus dur
maintenant c'est les eaux sociaux bon
les réseaux sociaux moi je vois là
dessus mais c'est la n est que quand je
joue venez y mêle et courriels le matin
j si la haine fera ses fans mais ça
devient way home est un bouc itunes et
une belle qualité animé s'amuse atteint
non mais on regarde au nom non mais j'ai
rien à des bons
films et 5h30 du matin son souhait de la
haine
bonne fan
plus car on a beaucoup beaucoup plus
avancé t envoyer des petits nains peut
trouver que le times
mais l'idée même des insultes et par une
personne se connecte peut-être insulté
par une personne avec be like qui ont
dit en désaccord avec toi c'est un chien
fini ça dérange pas mais ça tu vois la
nature humaine quand même incroyable
haye et 5h le matin le goy décide de
céder chine j'allais bien aujourd'hui et
ça vous donne pas envie de dire parce
que vous auriez les moyens dire la salut
au revoir j'avais envie de continuer au
contraire ça donnait ça je vous en donne
un petit pochon parce que honnêtement à
ces places là il ya quelque chose de
juste un petit peu triste pas pour le
moment pour eux zone ouais c'est vrai
quand tu deviens
anti-vaccins complotisme que tout en
avant sur des réseaux sociaux et à cause
des algorithmes tout la même gagne se
tient à santés sûr de ton côté ce que le
monde entier l'ak la bête l'entière est
avec toi pas moi
sacha plus la pandémie oui est-ce que
c'était au début difficile de faire la
dérision de rire de soi monsieur legault
soit dr arruda soit de l'association
compte tenu de ce qu'on vivait
collectivement
non
c'est à cette non parce que pour moi est
que dont le tous vécu la pandémie story
si l'enfant moi aussi j'étais enfermé
mais de regarder les complotistes garder
les fous de garder la gagne gardez les
politiques ont profité de ça je pense
être certes est parti conservateur dans
le maquis avec du mpr en cela par la
haine est fauché mais le mot est moins
franche et cet investissement en été ça
marche moins ils pensent juste voie
espérait hier au temps des bips bientôt
lipides rire de doctor who knows que
vous
l'avez vous n'êtes pas dire je peux pas
du sang site totalement libre face à ce
oui c'est ma job et moi j'ai joué bien
c'est la bêtise humaine j'ai une
certaine situation qu'est ce qu'on s'est
rendu compte les mois presque vide et
auteur de deux rapports de cet atelier
il yad'autres a pas écouté m vous vous
l'avez décidé je me souviens ce matin
avec des lunettes à
l'étagé une belle vue dans
sa poule de dhr et ils en ont fait un
saint ma job c'est de enlevée de son
piédestal les gens adorent ça petit
golan et ses pointes personnes est très
sain mais moi bon ce qui m'amène parler
de sein à la religion
salman au jury attaquer ou hindous
dernier
ça continue les caricatures de mahomet
par ailleurs est ce que vous vous êtes
aussi totalement libre de rire de toutes
les religions oui mais je peux pas donc
j'avais dit que je connais mais le mont
houy c'est de dire trouve une façon
simple de passer à côté de ça pour
pouvoir parler de salman rushdie de
trouver la situation crise est banal de
dire si la galaxy tab est horrible on se
rappelle des quelques notions de suite
dit oui tu as très chanceux du haut
canada dans certains pays auprès de même
s'avérer un succès non faut pas
s'arrêter là mais il faut que je trouve
des tout pour pouvoir en parler je le
décès d'un boulet ou même non gelée déjà
dessiné que j'ai dessiné j'avais fait un
dessin il était invisible envoyait 200
dalle jacket pieux gamme mais on le
voyait pour le tuba ils étaient visibles
c'est comme si sa reprise ray bd ce
n'est pas vous et vous auriez dû passer
alors à six a laissé un petit mail jeu
moche ça je sens que j'ai dessiné
mahomet mais je les fais un dixième
sauter d'une clope et divers autres
lieux pauvres au monde
j'ai pris goût de me faire l'assassiner
dans la rue mais j'ai le goût de trouver
une façon de pouvoir en parler s'était
dessiné des talibans mille fois parce
que les chrétiens les catholiques les
crimes sexuels se vous êtes souvent les
wiccans je suis mis il ya eu des crimes
sexuels je ne signe pas de multiples
entendu à james jones la semaine
dernière et voilà mais si si bonne des
gags bannière unimat
sexuelle voies pour le dessiner sociale
certains par malo mais je soutiendrai
pas le temps de mettre ma carrière à
risque parce que je veux pas de
redessiner le bonhomme est probable
parce que les caricaturistes vous êtes
un peu le canari dans la mine il jette
les indicateurs de la l2 greg liberté
près liberté de parole moi j'ai
l'impression que le cannabis taille et
sa connaissance très critiqué dans sa
cage lui à l'esprit pas beaucoup ça
change beaucoup et ça c'est en somme
énorme et donc aujourd'hui 2022 est
moins libre que voulait dire si nous
serons parle souvent de liberté je pense
que raconte beaucoup dit berthet mais
les réactions sont différentes si je
fais gaffe même un stand up quand même
je lisais je veux plus voir le spectacle
de stand up mais les 17 pays ce qu'on
appelle supporte pas de rudy guédé un
i-pod et lesbien dans les pas des lgbt
qu à l'esstic w et on n'est pas des
sillons du poteau de coire où dit il
faut qu'on puisse de quelque chose qui
vous pouvez aller oui je peux mais le
lendemain c'est ça votre les plaintes un
ferment alors s'ils m'appellent la
presse qui m'appuient
porte pas attention à ce tout va pour le
mieux mais c'est clair et net que si je
dessine
le pape j'ai des jeunes qui vont me dit
que la foudre de dieu vont tomber dessus
puis-je vous brûler dans les dents les
tonguiens enfin le laisse pas se
restreint quand même les sujets ou et
des sujets qu'ils viennent plus
difficile à aborder à moi de trouver une
façon de les dépasser il réparait des
peuples autochtones du ciel ringer vous
avez fait une caricature de jean
chrétien dans un totem parce qu'il était
mieux à faire
pourriez-vous faire ça demain matin
ce matin de jean chrétien mais oui je le
traiterai probablement différent
différemment mais je pourrais le faire
j'ai dessiné des affaires d'autochtones
j'ai pas mais moi la perte d'un plu ou
déplu et magasins mais où est jean n'est
fait
continuons notre nouveau chef
gabriel nadeau-dubois l'avez vous
trouvée et honda qui laisse y est voilà
aussi gabriel nadeau du bourg de voile
abyssinie 100 m manon anna les herbes 10
mais c'était encore ça résume encore le
personnage aujourd'hui sociale la
dernière fois aux sociétés vieux
mais je dis c'est encore la même chose
idéale de leurs publicités change d'ère
changer d'ère promet mans annonce toi
celui je veux m'appuyer d'état c'est
cultiver pour savoir que m à travers
l'hôpital vient de différence pire mais
une petite flèche en plus vous vous y
êtes comme moi regarde c'est très
différent mais les couleurs l'image des
deux faces qui regarde dans des
directions différentes
s'esquisser soviétique donc ça ça ça
remet au goût du jour en vieille
caricature sont pas capables de passer
outre ce donc là il veut s'éloigner de
madame c'est que j'ai que j'adore
ultrafin maintenant c'est et les jantes
mais ils sont dix duos se détachent et a
fait doux à lui barrent garde d'ailleurs
et six gendarmes
s'affairent la soviétique ou et
complaisamment 70e
paul st pierre plamondon
il y avait un nouveau retenu il faut pas
être trop dur
presque parce que voici
c'est comme éco gardes ya de la douleur
que si qui a dit il ya un message classe
dingue intelligents dits structurés paul
journet fait un texte excellent dans la
présence se balader y déclamer et pour
cali smati qu'il pointe pour beaucoup
j'y arrive d'un meeting cette personne
ne fait bon gag l'année passée toutes
les caricatures et j'en ai fait un idiot
organise impoli parti n'a elle pas plus
que 10 personnes ou ramos le choc
possible
mais c'est un bon gars sont pas un bon
gars sont au filet la marche avec le
petit nouveau éric duel si loin au
niveau des télés merci et règles
d'exister si c'est pas moi c'est une
frappe à stx ça c'est le genre de
personnage pour vous ces cracks le ca a
plié mais des heures parce que ça me
prend du temps à fin mai mais petits
plats une fois que c'est fait le joujou
avec cependant des années de la gauche
inapte au noir un accent il s'avoue gay
il donne l'impression in an par personne
n'en parle jamais sommet équité accent
et en plus ils printemps de dis que
prend sa douche et que ces paradis
latin car si ça grandin d'agrandir la
douche n'est pas là je l'avais fait avec
son dans une douche avec son pack
dispense mains au savon
seules les plaintes que j'ai de saussure
du courrier est horrible puis par contre
on voit que les mac il la puise parce
que les vocabulaires tombe avec beaucoup
de fautes de mou du chien album où les
sacs et c'est toujours à ce niveau là le
matin
les participants
les chefs eux mêmes les chefs mais vous
avez développé une relation qui est plus
vieux que reconnaît
us qui vous en parlait ce que vous avez
des contacts avec leur entourage à ce
que des pleins comment ça va j'ai connu
mme françois legault afin qu'ils soient
élus un peu plus personnellement gens
condamnés dans des restaurants avec sa
charmante compagne et ils sont pauvres
ils provenaient à ta table dimanche
peut-être qu'il pense parce que des
dessins que pas aimer mais il voit
surtout dans ta que je faisais jouer
lors de la flac avec lui et était aux
personnages favoris blanche et mon bon
ami serge miot toujours produite et
sketches très élogieux pour me mettre en
valeur et non pas mal toujours pour vous
niez géré monsieur de gaulle ni taire
une voix posée tu peux jeter les habits
de rage en études à lille parce que les
ghettos jouable
de la sauce de gags c'est juste un gag
c'est comme pour faut pas s'arrêter à ça
mais il sent bon la barre est ce que les
policiers avec qui j'avais été injuste
je vous demander ce que vous regrettiez
des choses que
stéphane dion leur offre leur mit un
dépôt
de mourgues et et où stéphane dion
c'était trop de voir plus je l'avais
disney euros dont j'avais dessiné en
rongeant bouddhiste est un enjeu
sauvegarde stéphane c'est un tout petit
nombre et l'âge des fêtards a pu
visionner tu m'avais dit il faut plus
faire ce fait je l'avais dit ce n'est la
mecque et pinard et d'embellir ce tâche
mais là il faut garde le kcl vos patrons
de ces jo il faut s'occuper sa gamme
c'est peut être le cas oui le casse de
wade visiter la fromagerie oui le foot
c'est toxique est tellement contentes de
ce dessin le mais il a fait la pire a
fait citer la photo le journal de
montréal le portier un premier pas que
duceppe et tout parlera ici est pire que
votre qu'elle découvre la tour entamée
salles de suivi pendant des années et
maintenant
monsieur duceppe gel que je rencontre
s'est tenue à quelques-uns de mes
émissions télévision tout était parfait
même ce chrétien écrit là-dessus pidoux
et les
ingrédiens cette fille-là y est y aime
ça serge chapleau je vous souhaite une
bonne campagne à vous merci à vous aussi
quant à lui